laurent est ce que tu sais qui et
grichka qui est igor bien sûr bien sûr
je perds ces dernières qui servent à je
voulais qu'une et je vais me délecter de
te voir ramer comme un porc igor et
grichka bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes né le
29 août 1949 à menton
alors on va on va tout de suite voilà
dix-huit évacuer cette histoire du
menton parce que j'ai rien dit mais non
tu as dit à menton alors pour quelles
raisons avez-vous un menton comme ça je
vais tout le monde se pose des questions
bon là toi tu sais pas moi je m'appelle
non sérieusement ben c'est ce que
beigbeder a dès hier c'est depuis qu'il
est passé notre mission en fait il a eu
le sentiment que il allait se
transformer en un troisième frère de
l'enfant est dit mais pas du tout en
réalité c'est igor qui a peut-être voulu
ressembler à gré jusqu'à ou vice versa
et en un certain sens on ressemble plus
à personne
ouais nan mais c'est dû à quoi à force
de se prendre la tête
alors les budgets de monde non
sérieusement c'est comme ça vous êtes
comme ça oui c'est quelque chose que
vous avez fait non c'est parce que tout
le monde en parle en réalité il n'ya
rien de c'est une option
500 mo farah ont un petit peu non c'est
pas du tout c'est la première fois qu'on
vous en parle
non c'est vrai ah oui c'est vrai les
gens on va vous en parler nous on vous
envoie une émission on dit ou ichi noble
sa démission décontracté où tout passe
et wayne allemand non mais ça c'est non
les gens bêtes qu'on vous en parle
non sérieux à jamais bon ça vous embête
pas jamais j'ai parfaitement quadrillé
normes n'ont d'ailleurs personne ne la
tue trouve ainsi toi quand même tu peux
aussi plus ou moins que toi toi c'est
qui alors oui mais les huit équipes lui
céder jusqu'à merde annoncé go girl est
d'accord on n'aura pas la réponse sur le
menton non mais en fait c'est parce que
je crois qu'il ya pas de réponse en
réalité parce que toi tu ma morphologie
et mature partie de je te tiens tu me
tiens au fait accompli sa dot mais si
votre morphologie naturel danser en fait
qu'il est vraiment scientifique
bon cette énigme étant presque résolus
pas vraiment encore nous allons passer
aux actes igor et grichka bonsoir dont
vous êtes né le 29 août 1949 et igor à
15h10 et grichka à 15h50 ce que j'ai à
vous n'êtes pas des vrais jumeaux en
même temps voilà rien retardataires tout
le monde pense continuer fait qu'on se
sent beaucoup qu'on est vrai que ce
n'est ni got n'en sais rien mais on est
faux est en réalité
quelqu'un nous a même dit on est
probablement une catégorie intermédiaire
entre les vrais et les faux parce qu'on
se ressemble plus que des faux et moins
que des vrais connais juste entre les
deux jeux prendre des notes comme oui
alors vous êtes issu d'un mariage entre
deux grandes familles une famille russe
et une famille autrichienne
il faut dire que votre mère était la
fille car le mélange pas d'une princesse
autrichienne et d'un chanteur noir
américain possédant un quart de san siro
qui vous indiquent c'est vrai nom c'est
ainsi oui et d un grand-père en fait
seahawks n'étaient donc vous avez un
côté siouxie d'ailleurs
c'est vrai alors vous avez une enfance
peu commune parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que igor et grichka et tdd
surdoué à l'âge de 3 ans vous par
l'elysée le français l'anglais
l'allemand couramment non partage à deux
c'est pour ça qu'un bon alors ce cas
c'est étonnant à la même époque
vous savez jouer du piano debout sur un
détail pour vous à l'âge de 6 ans vous
savez conduire des voitures à l'âge de 8
ans vous savez faire tous les travaux de
la ferme à l'âge de 15 ans vous pilotez
des planeurs et à l'âge de 16 ans vous
pilotez des avions et des hélicoptères
voilà l'orage et compte toujours pipi au
lit dont il ya quand même un après le
bac que vous avez bien entendu à 14 ans
je redis en sketches et la brasseur la
hisser au dessus des normes
voilà donc après le bac qu'ils ont à 14
ans vous écrivez des nouvelles et vous
êtes médiatisé et c'est comme ça qu'à 18
ans vous vous retrouvez à présenter tant
x sur tf1 émission culte s'il en fût
voilà le jeu de ces souvent qu il de
thierry ouais ça a duré 10 ans assez a
duré de 1979 à 1989
vous pensiez pas que ça durerait aussi
longtemps au départ non parce que chaque
année on se disait ben voyons qu'est ce
qu'on va faire cette année et puis on
nous appelait vers le moins de sept
flamands pour nous dire voilà avait
coûté si vous êtes d'accord on repart ça
a duré dix ans et une émission assez
visionnaire parce que quand on fait le
compte de ce que vous avez raconté dans
cette émission on se rend compte qu'ils
étaient les premiers à parler de bill
gates
à l'époque personne ne le connaissait
microsoft personne ne savait ce que
c'était vous parler d'internet que à
l'époque on appelle encore interne ex et
vous êtes les premiers à en parler c'est
nous qui l'avons baptisé comme ça ouais
ouais parce qu on appelait pas ça c'est
ça alors merci c'est la merde mais voit
pas encore de mettet m'étais venant
devant vous que c'est vrai que ce sera
beaucoup plus simple donc toi tu es
griche mettons le grichka chez les noirs
et les blancs dont vous êtes les
premiers à baptiser internet internet et
internet
pourquoi parce que on a on a eu l'idée
finalement on s'est dit il va y avoir un
jour des ordinateurs en réseau
ce sont donc des autres connectés les
uns aux autres interconnexion voilà et
pour faire plus court intérim ex dont
l'ex banque internet menacé vous voilà
vous avez été les premiers à parler de
la domotique
qu'est ce que c'est laurent la domotique
géant jugé ce mot là mais tu vas - tu
vois que ça sert le grec et le latin
aujourd'hui si vanité françois doivent
continuer à apprendre le grec et le
latin mais bien sûr qu'il faut qu'il
continue âge a pris au moins trois ans
de boutique l'ordinateur contrôler la
maison j'étais très fier à ce que j'ai
appris un mois françois imbeau inutile
mais c'est quoi boustrophédon il m'a
appris à ça je connais pas c'est quoi
c'est une écriture archaïque qui va dans
tous les sens comme le goff sillon du
golfe
j'ai [ __ ] revanche pas pierre forgues
vous êtes aussi les premiers à parler du
décodage du génome 1 et c'est vous qui
avez inventé le fameux titre e égal m6
alors quand vous l'avez raconté m6 ils
ont trouvé ça nul 1 au départ la
première départ n'était pas dans
l'émission ça va c'est un bon concept
allez on y va mais par contre le titre
c'est quelque chose qui il ya une erreur
grave donc finalement quelques années
plus tard nicolas de tavernot vous
appeler pour vous dire est ce que votre
titre vous me le donnes auriez vous le
vous lui avez donné enfin j'imagine
qu'il avait vendu j'espère pour vous non
non mais alors ce qui est le plus drôle
c'est que pendant une année
igor était aux usa igor et grichka a
fait les deux rôles dans l'émission mais
ça c'était quand même très très beau
parce que quand j'ai revu les missions
beaucoup étaient en rentrant en france
je me suis dit c'est quand même allons
voir et je me suis pas du tout rendu
compte parce que comme les en large
nous nous prenait à tous les deux il y
avait donc un acteur qui était à ma
place mais dans les tous les plans
rapprochés qu'est ce qui a changé de
coiffure est en fait il était à la fois
lui et moi oui
mêlant directeur de tf1 afin d être des
programmes un jour m'a dit mon rêve
c'est bien ce que vous avez fait votre
frère des gommes plus est ce que vous
faites par avec les gonzesses
ça vous jamais rêvé ce truc tous les
joueurs tous les jumeaux ont fait ça
tout juste que non ah bon vraiment pas
non non parce que c'est parce que c'est
énorme le mec il jumeaux ils faits
d'amour avec la gonzesse il se casse
henin qui vient notre vient pas c'est ça
lorsque froid j'ai un grand boum
familiale north imaginer arrêter de dire
des trucs comme ça
alors après une feinte et en xc avant en
france 2 et rayons x puisque maintenant
vous êtes sous une forme virtuelle tous
les samedis à 19 55 sur france 2 vous
disparaissez de la télé pendant dix ans
et vous passez des thèses
alors là attention on s'accroche grichka
l'attestent ces fluctuations quantiques
de la signature de la métrique de
l'échelle de planck l'échelle de près
les chercheurs la grosse [ __ ] à dudule
la capsule apollo bien circulation
tandis que la signature l'échelle de
planck et igor
la thèse est à topologie de l'espace
temps à l'échelle 0 oui mais c'est vrai
mais au fond pour la grande question qui
dépose et d'ailleurs c'est à temps pour
t il pas la question c'est le début de
la question de schopenhauer pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose plutôt que
rien des questions qui se posent
évidemment c'est quoi la fin du début il
ya quoi derrière l'univers
en fait ça mais laurent mais tu crois
pas si bien dire mais je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas la réponse mais ça mais c'est
chez grasset qui s'appelle avant le big
bang voilà alors quoi moi j'ai prévu une
pression formidable
alors quoi on est constitué un petit
riff ont situé rappelons que le big bang
a eu lieu à mardi ouais tu vois en toi
tu étais pas la tête des piscines voilà
c'est dément non d'abord est ce qu'on
pourrait dire ce qu'est le big bang
rapidement et après on verra ce qu'ils
avaient avant le big bang
d'accord absolument bon alors le big
bang le big bang d'abord c'est un mot
qui était inventée par un auteur à la
fois de science fiction il s'appelle
fred hoyle mais aussi d'ailleurs un très
très grand un des plus grands
scientifiques de l'école de cambridge
dans les années 50 il invente ce mot en
51 et derrière ça c'est aussi un état de
l'espace temps c'est à dire que nous
vivons dans un univers qui est en
expansion il nous offre un petit peu
comme un ballon j'en connais bien
compris jusque là ça va jusque là ça va
et si maintenant on rembobine le film à
l'envers
et bien ce ballon il va devenir de plus
en plus petit jusqu'à une certaine étape
qu'on appelle le mur de planck dix
puissance moins 34
c'est juste avant le big bang ça c'est
non le moment du big bang le big bang
commence au mur de planck d'accueillir
un moment si par exemple je prends cette
feuille de papier ja des chiffres non
non je vais tomber je vais tomber sur le
mur de planck c'est à dire dix puissance
moins 33 cm c'est la limite de
divisibilité de la matière on peut pas
descendre en dessous donc l'univers à un
moment il était comme une petite
particule élémentaire absolument
infinitésimale qui avait la longueur de
plans et la question qu'on doit se poser
tu t'es sommes opposés toi aussi
prononcé des propos c'est non non non
est-ce que non non non non non rien
faire
d'où ma question à moi alors quoi ça
sert
alors alors alors pour répondre à cette
question cette grande question en 1999
et 2002 donc on soutient à l'école
polytechnique ces deux thèses qui nous
ont occupés comme tu l'as dit pendant
dix ans dix ans de travaux de
mathématiques avec des mathématiciens
dans le monde entier on a voyagé un
petit peu partout on a été aux états
unis en russie au japon partout et on
revient effectivement avec ses thèses
c'est facile avec une calculette
première chose que coûte laurent oui
surtout quand année de bep à leur
première chose en public parce que quand
on fait une thèse
effectivement elle ne peut être acceptée
que si elle est publiée dans des organes
scientifique alors on a publié ici j'en
ai eu en comité de les verrez vous un
comité de lecture bravo avait publié un
petit peu ça m'est arrivé c'est un truc
lotois alors et alors effectivement là
la plus difficile de ces revues
s'appelle annals of mathematics et
l'autre s'appelle and half of physics
c'est celle là ce sont les annales de
physique et c'est là que nous avons
publié nos travaux en 2002
quelques jours après c'est à dire en
fait 48 heures après par internet
on a vu exploser dans le monde entier
une vague qui est à la fois un
discussions de contestation polémique et
c'est entre octobre 2002 et janvier 2003
et ça fait le tour du monde
quand on tape singularité initiale c'est
à dire donc ce point nous avons cherché
il y à 2 millions aujourd'hui de
référence sur ce point et bien en fait
c'est cet article là qui vient en tête
alors non alors ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses et attiré par le maire vous dites
l'univers a une origine d'ordre
mathématiques tout tout tout tout tout
les êtres vivants que nous sommes sont
précédées par une information cette
information c'est le code génétique tout
simplement et nous avons dit et bien
avant l'univers physique que nous
connaissons qui caractérisé par des
structures à petite échelle et à très
grande échelle et bien avant lui avant
l'univers tel que nous le connaissons la
réalité telle que nous la connaissons et
bien il ya une réalité qui est précédé
par c'est un code est un code génétique
de l'univers
le code oui c'est ça en cause
cosmologique quoi d'une avant la
belgique a elle annoncé sa cote que jane
la fille alia de la mathématique avant
la fusion de la magliana mathématiques
et tout ça ça se passe effectivement
en-deça du mur de planck c'est dire que
quand on descend au delà la physique
s'arrête elle bloque d'ailleurs toute la
physique tous les physiciens théoriciens
disons peut pas remonter si on a eu une
polémique aussi dur parce qu'elle était
bur en 2002 il ya eu vraiment une
tempête mondiale là dessus c'est pour
trois raisons la première raison c'est
que c'est une question interdite
personne ne se pose la question de
savoir ce qu'il y avait avant parce que
les scientifiques disent s'être absurde
personne ne trouvera jamais la réponse
première interdiction
deuxième raison je crois qu'on a trouvé
quelque chose mais c'est ce quelques
jours ne passe pas par la physique ça
passe par les mathématiques et notamment
par une théorie nouvelle on a eu la
chance d'avoir un directeur de thèse qui
était un de ceux qui ont inventé cette
théorie qu'on appelle la théorie de
déformation des groupes classiques c'est
une théorie des groupes quoi antique et
en fait ça permet de remonter jusqu'aux
jusqu'à un point que nous avons appelé
le point zéro de l'espace temps ni et ce
point là qui est en effet un point situé
au nord du pôle nord si on peut dire et
bien ce point il correspond à un moment
où l'univers tout entier était zéro
c'est-à-dire n'y avait rien n'y avait
pas de l'univers physique il n'y avait
qu'une information
c'est ce que nous appelons effectivement
le codage entre guillemets cosmologie
mais c'est assez fascinant de penser que
toute cette réalité qui nous entoure les
milliards de galaxies les milliards des
toiles par ganassi tout ça avant le mur
de planck était sur un point si vous
avez une preuve
oui on en a trois il y en a trois en a
trois en attendant la très important
bonne question d'habitude il ya trois à
3-3 preuve la première preuve elle a
fait le tour du monde en 80 3 c'est
l'observation qui était faite par un
satellite de la nasa qui s'appelle wmap
et qui observait le font en fait le
fameux fond cosmique cosmologique 300
mille ans donc juste après le big bang
ou envoient des fluctuations
effectivement de deux des températures à
l'origine et bien ça c'est une preuve
que ce que tu disais tout à l'heure
c'est à la fluctuations quantiques de la
signature des métriques existe
honneur il reste deux preuves je sais
les ai parlé mes clients à les condamner
pas les rays au bûcher trop vite même
télé d'abord oui il parle comme ils lui
ont dit un cantique de la night line
alors oui mais comme il est publié il
connaît deux autres oeuvres allait
rapidement parce que très important
l'univers est en expansion on l'a dit
tout à l'heure mais cette expansion
s'accélère est là aussi les satellites
d'observation ont pu faire cette preuve
pourquoi parce qu'en fait les supernovas
qui sont des étoiles qui explosa marque
à l'antenne qu'ils aient alors pardon
c'est vraiment alors on va dire les
hypers donc qui explosent et bien leur
lumière est tellement faible qu'on voit
qu'elle s'échappe vers l'infini beaucoup
plus rapidement qu'on ne le pensait donc
ça veut dire que l'expansion de l'espace
temps s'accélère sous la poussée de ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie noire
or l'énergie noire cette sauce et
l'énergie sombre ou noire
et bien sûr elle est présente partout et
elle explique elle explique en fait il
ya une source
et cette source c'est le fameux point
zéro de l'espace temps et la troisième
le
[Musique]
à vous devez en fumée de la bonne car
ils ont rebondi en troisième ça doit
être fort et la transition je sais que
les champs c'est le service public doit
parler
le reste du capital celle là elle
remonte en fait à 1935 elle n'a pas été
trouvée à cette époque là mais einstein
legrand einstein était un adversaire de
la théorie du big bang en fait il n'a
jamais cru que l'univers était en
expansion et il était tellement
adversaires de cette idée que lorsqu en
1922 le grand friedman un russe qui
était un ingénieur mathématicien
absolument splendide a découvert fait
pas des cons comme quand tu découvres
quand il est cool j rich 4.0 quand il
découvre le point zéro de l'espace-temps
einstein lui dit il est tellement
furieux qu'ils jettent l'article par
terre il le piétiner il dit c'est pas
possible ça peut pas se passer comme ça
les verts et statique il n'y a pas
d'expansion et en 1935 il publie un
papier en publiant effectivement ce
temps les gars il va c'est exactement ça
et il se donne effectivement pour tâche
de démontrer qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
effectivement ni d'expansion ni surtout
de corrélation entre des particules
séparés dans l'espace temps
cb
à noter
et
[Musique]
samedi
depuis on
je ne veux pas montrer
mais ouais
messieurs
est ce que je propose c'est qu'on voit
en quoi vous croyez vraiment et qu'on
fasse une une interview croyances
attention est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui est ce que vous croyez au diable non
est ce que vous croyez que dans l'avenir
tout le monde sera habillé avec des
combinaisons argentées
non car bien sûr si si c'est une âme
novices et honda est ce que vous croyez
au voyage dans le temps non si le voyage
dans le temps avait existé des voyageurs
du futur seraient déjà venus nous voir
mais tu as raison personnelle juste est
ce que vous croyez aux extraterrestres à
vous croyez extraterrestre est
complètement oui mais alors là c'est une
croyance c'est une certitude
scientifique parce que oui on est tous
qu'on passe également à ce qu'elle est
ce que vous croyez qu'on peut se
réincarner dans un meuble par exemple
non non est ce que vous croyez à la
colonisation de mars
oui oui oui à demain à l'antenne deux
fois est ce que vous croyez à la force
comme dans star wars
oui parce qu'en fait la force en un
certain sens c'est la quintessence de
respect a pas du tout là c'est la face
aux besoins d'énergie noire énergie
noire
est ce que vous croyez si ça se trouve
que l'humanité n'est que le rêve d'un
chien non est ce que vous croyez aux
fantômes vampires loups garous à toutes
ces conneries
non ce sont des personnages de la
réalité fantastique ils sont faits pour
être admiré dans les romans en fait
ouais mais pas mais il existe pas du
tout d'accord il ne veut y a pas eu de
résistance
est ce que vous croyez à l'innocence de
michael jackson
j'aurais tendance à dire j'aurais
tendance à dire à sa place qu'on ne sort
de l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment donc
c'est pas la peine de mort est ce que
vous croyez à une quatrième dimension
oui bah oui oui bah oui mais oui puisque
toutes les attentions
or même 6e temps en panne si non il ya
bien un 5/5
est ce que vous croyez aux chaussettes
blanches avec des mocassins ça dépend
comme elles sont portés mais oui quand
même
winters mathieu moi non mais lui est ce
que vous croyez que le clonage devrait
être accessible à tous à part pour nan
lavilliers non non non non c'est
strictement non et d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas d'avenir dans le clonage pour ne
vraiment pas non parce que c'est une
illusion
tous les temps du clonage nous nous en
fait c'est pas mal ça c'est une forme de
clown
donc le clonage qui croit pas du tout
non seulement j'y crois pas mais je
trouve que c'est une illusion de dire
bravo
il existe en ce moment aux états unis
par exemple une société qui
commercialise des des animaux en les
clones ans et en disant voilà c'est la
reproduction de votre de votre animal
favori or c'est tout à fait faux parce
que quand on prend par exemple un chat
qui avait une tache au bout de la queue
elle se retrouve sur le sol regorge
prédit un chiffre un chat ou un chien
peu importe mais en tout cas en tout cas
dans le dans le codage de l'animal alors
que tous les caractères sont supposés
être les mêmes
il se trouve que des processus
aléatoires intervienne et que l'animal
n'est jamais le même nom que c'est déjà
une imposture au départ non à la
dernière question la plus importante est
ce que vous croyez la météo d'evelyne
dhéliat à la météo en fait pas tellement
parce que là aussi à des phénomènes
aléatoires et qui font qu'on n'est pas
capable encore aujourd'hui de prévoir
quoi que ce soit ma terreur elizabeth
teissier non en fait non plus c'était le
pôle eldar en bout c'est vrai
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu